but we often hear hyperbole at moments
like this but it is no exaggeration
today to see that this is the most
significant and historic Constitutional
Court ruling that we've had in all of
our lifetimes I mean let's just be blunt
about the significance of that ruling it
is found that the Prime Minister acted
unlawfully and seeking to pootle
Parliament's that he had no good reason
for doing so that in fact it was about
evading scrutiny and closing down
parliamentary accountability and all at
a time of political and constitutional
crisis for the country I think what
should happen now firstly is that
Parliament should be back in session I
understand from my colleagues in the
House of Commons that Parliament is
likely to be back in session tomorrow
morning but secondly and I don't see
this lately but I'm going to be blunt or
than Jeremy Corbyn was in the clip I've
just heard I think Boris Johnson should
resign this is a prime minister who has
been phoned by the UK Supreme Court to
have acted unlawfully seeking to evade
scrutiny and with a good reason and if
the rules of democracy are to mean
anything then I think a prime minister
with any honor would tender his
resignation today what about the Queen's
position well I think the issue here is
the behavior of the Prime Minister the
Queen was presented with the the
proposal as is the way these things as I
understand that normally happens this is
about the conduct and the behavior of a
prime minister who is or should be how'd
he know it sought to prolong Parliament
accountable to Parliament and you know I
think the focus today should be on that
so I do believe in a stress I don't see
this lightly but I think if the rules of
democracy are to mean anything if
accountability is to mean anything then
this is a prime minister that is not fit
for office Parliament's principal
priority should continue to be to block
an audio breaks at the end of October
but if the Prime Minister isn't prepared
to do the decent and honorable thing in
tendering his resignation then I think
Parliament should quickly come together
to force this play minister from office